[MUSIC PLAYING]
IL-SUNG LEE: What you're
going to learn is talk is--
first of all, what's Cloud
HSM and why would you use it?
And then, I'll talk a little bit
about some of the new Cloud HSM
features that we're
announcing today as well.
And then afterwards,
Matt will come on stage
and explain to you about
Customer Managed Encryption
Keys and explain how it works,
and how you leverage Customer
Magic Encryption Keys to
help meet your compliance
requirements.
Now, at the end this
talk, I can pretty much
guarantee that you'll learn
something new, at least
one thing, and my
only ask of you
is that you please
do not fall asleep.
These are really, really
comfortable chairs
and we need you
to pay attention.
OK.
So forgive me if this is going
through some of the things
that you may already
know, but I always
find it's useful to
kind of get level set
and talk about what
are the options
that we have available today.
So we have a wide
spectrum of different ways
to do encryption of your data
at rest in our Google Cloud.
And so by default, we
encrypt everything,
and if you've ever talked
to me before, I'll tell you
that we're not going
to give you a choice,
you have to encrypt
your data at rest,
and there's no
option to turn off.
Google was the first cloud
to do this, where it just
became an automatic thing.
And if you do nothing,
then we will make sure
that's encrypted
at least one layer
and we'll do all the key
management and everything
else inside internally through
our own internal KMS system.
Now, you can also
use Cloud KMS, which
we introduced a few years
back, to actually go and create
your own keys.
And with those keys, you
can support something
called Customer Managed
Encryption Keys,
and what that
allows you to do is
that it allows you to
leverage the data at rest,
but protect that
data at rest using
a key that's under your
control in the Cloud KMS.
And because of the work
that we did with Cloud HSM,
you can use both Cloud KMS and
Cloud HSM keys synonymously.
OK, so you can actually use
this to actually protect data
with your keys in Cloud HSM.
And then finally
we have customer
supplied encryption keys.
So this is something that we
provide for support of both GCE
and GCS, and what
this feature does
is that when you go and
try to access your data
you have to provide a secret
along with your API call.
OK, and so we don't persist
that secret, which is
necessary to unlock the data.
And so for that reason, if
you don't access the data,
it's really, really, really hard
for us to actually get access
to anything.
Now, the one thing that I just
want to point out about that
is that it's only
available for GCS and GCE,
and a good reason for this
is that we really don't have
access to that key otherwise.
And so if we don't
have access to the key,
we can't do things
that are offline,
like compaction or logical
backups or anything like that.
So it'll only be for
those two services.
Now, what's an HSM?
How many people here use an HSM?
OK, good-- actually, I
would say over half of you.
So for the other half, an HSM
is a hardware security module.
It's basically a
physical device that's
used for managing and
performing crypt operations.
Now, there's a lot of
reasons why people use these.
You can create keys
that are non exportable
and the hardware device will
provide certain guarantees
to prevent the keys from
being exported or exposed.
And they often provide
some guarantees around
tamper evident and
tamper resistance.
So things like if you
try to extract the key,
it'll be something that
you'll be made aware of.
And in the extreme cases,
if they can't potentially
zero out the keys, as well,
so that the attacker can't
actually get access to anything.
And the final thing there
is that they are often
FIPS 140-2 certified.
FIPS 140-2 is a
certification from NIST
that basically defines
crypto modules,
and so it covers everything
from the implementation
of algorithms to the way the
random numbers are generated
and everything else.
Most times people are
using these devices
because they either are
very heavily regulated
and so these things are
often helpful in getting
through your compliance
auditor, or they're
required to protect
high valued keys,
so financial
institutions, for example,
are very, very big
on these things.
Now, what we've
done with Cloud HSM
is that we provide
the managed service
on top of these devices.
So for the other half who
have actually had HSMs,
you know that they can be
a little bit challenging
sometimes to actually manage.
And so we have taken that
burden and we manage everything
to the point where
all you see is an API
to do the key management
and do key generation
encryption/decryption,
things like that.
And so there's really
nothing for you to do.
We actually manage it
and we fully scale it.
We do auto patching.
We do the backups of
the keys, everything.
So there's nothing
for you to do.
Now, one of the things
that you might be asking
is why would I
use our Cloud HSM?
Well, compliance is, again,
a major motivator for this.
We are using FIPS 140-2
Level 3 certified.
And so that may or
may not be important.
If you don't know
what that means,
then probably this
doesn't matter to you.
But if you do
care, then you know
that Level 3 is sort
of the gold standard
that everyone looks for now.
And you can only achieve Level
3 through hardware devices,
you can't do this with software.
Regionalization-- so one of
the interesting properties
of the service
that we've created
is that when you create a
key in our Cloud HSM service,
that key is
cryptographically bound
to the HSMs within that region.
So if you create a key
in, say, US Central 1,
then only those
HSMs in US Central 1
are able to actually
go and use those keys
and perform crypto operations.
OK, it's just that
there's a strong binding
cryptographically
between the keys
and the devices themselves.
We will eventually
support a global region
and we're working on
multi-regions right now.
But currently we have this
deployed in several regions
across the United
States and Europe.
And for those people who
are already using Cloud KMS,
then there's actually
no changes necessary.
It's the same API.
It's just one flag when you
actually create the key,
and then everything else
is exactly the same.
I should have mentioned
earlier that if you
need to ask any questions,
please feel free.
I have a little bit of hard time
seeing because it's so bright,
but just wave your arms wildly
and I'll probably see you.
OK, great.
Now, I want to make a
couple announcements.
One is that Cloud HSM
is generally available,
it was actually generally
available a few months ago.
But in case you didn't
know, it's GA now,
so if the GA label
is important for you,
then you have it right now.
And, more importantly, we have
the Singapore region live.
So today we have it available in
three regions across the United
States, two in Europe, and
now we have one in Asia,
and we're rapidly increasing
the number of data centers
that we will be supporting.
And you should see
in the near future
that we will be covered
almost everywhere that you
expect cloud to be.
Oh and one more thing,
I'd like to also announce
that key import is now
available in alpha.
OK, so with this, you'll
now be able to-- at least
for the alpha, to import your
symmetric keys into our Cloud
HSM.
OK, and it'd be done in a
very secure manner where
you will not have to worry
about the keys being exposed.
Now, in the beta,
we'll expand this
to support other types
of keys and import it
into the software.
But for now, you can actually
import this into the HSMs.
And the way that works is
that we use a method called--
well, it's a [INAUDIBLE]
method, so just forgive me
for a brief moment
where I step in
to a little but more
technical jargon.
But we're using the RSA AES Key
Wrap, and essentially the way
that the process works is
that the HSMs will create
a public private key pair with
the private key only available
within the HSM, so we
don't have access to it.
And then you can
export that public key,
take it to your key
management device,
and then on your key
you would have to do this
process called AES Key Wrap.
And essentially,
the process says
is that your key manager
would have to go and create
an AES Key to wrap
your key, or the key
that you want to import.
And then the public key
that you just download
would wrap the AES Key, and then
you'd take that and bring that
back up to our cloud.
And then our HSMs are
able to unwrap everything,
all within the HSM boundary.
MATTHEW DRISCOLL: My
name is Matt Driscoll.
As I said at the beginning,
I'm product manager
and I focus a lot on Customer
Managed Encryption Keys.
So what is CMEK?
CMEK is a feature that allows
you to control the encryption
keys that are used to
protect your data at rest
in Google Cloud.
This is a really,
really important feature
if you need to show control
for regulatory or compliance
reasons over the
protection of your data.
We'll talk in a second
in a little more
detail about where this
is available on GCP today.
But just very quickly, supported
in BigQuery, Compute Engine,
Persistent Disk,
in cloud storage,
and in our Dataproc product.
So how does CMEK work?
Actually, to understand
how CMEK works,
you first need to know a
little bit about how encryption
at rest works within Google.
So Il-Sung mentioned
at the beginning
that we provide
default encryption
at rest for all of your
data in Google Cloud.
So we'll start there.
When we provide this default
encryption at rest, what we do
is we take data as it
comes in and we split it
into small chunks.
Each of those chunks
of data is then
encrypted with a
data encryption key.
Then that data and it's
encrypted data encryption key
is distributed across Google's
storage infrastructure
and stored.
So when you come
to Google and you
decide that default encryption
at rest is sufficient,
this is generally the
scheme that we use.
So when you use CMEK,
we're adding essentially
an extra layer into this.
Each chunk is still encrypted
with a data encryption key.
But then that data encryption
key is wrapped with a KMS key.
We call that KMS key
the key encryption key.
So what will happen when
you put the data to rest
is the service that is storing
your data will call out to KMS,
it will wrap the data
encryption key with the KMS key
that you've
indicated, and then it
will store the encrypted
data encryption
key and the data chunk in
whatever storage system
it's using.
So there's some
interesting properties
of this that are really,
really useful for compliance.
The most important
is auditability.
So every time that
we put data to rest,
we actually call out to KMS,
and so you can get a data access
log and a log of the encrypt or
decrypt of the data encryption
key.
And you can use that to go
monitor access to your data
through our key
management system.
Also to the services
that use KMS for CMEK,
it's transparent if
the key is in an HSM
or if the key is in software.
So all of the sort of value
that you get from cloud HSM
is available with the
same configuration
that you would use
for a software key.
This is really powerful.
Like, we actually
totally manage, make it
totally transparent
to you, the customer,
that we have HSMs behind the
scenes protecting your data.
So what are some best
practices for CMEK?
There's two things
I want to highlight.
First is regional alignment.
When you actually go
to configure CMEK,
you'll notice that
some of the services
will only allow you
to configure keys
that are in the same region
as the resource they're
protecting.
We push customers to do this
for resiliency and for latency.
And it's occasionally
a place where
folks stub their toe if they
don't know this constraint.
And the second
separation of duties.
So how the services that
store your data talk to KMS
is through a service account.
When we provision that service
account on your behalf,
or we have tools
to do this for you
when you create CMEK
protected resources in the UI,
we give that service
account a very minimal set
of permissions.
It only can encrypt and
decrypt with the KMS key.
So when you're using
KMS in general,
we encourage you to
think very deeply
about what permissions are
actually needed for any given
principle accessing KMS and keep
those permissions to a minimum.
So CMEK support on Google Cloud.
Today, we support CMEK
across four services.
And I want to give you
some detail about it.
In BigQuery, we support
CMEK at the table level.
So anytime you create a table,
you can indicate a CMEK key,
and we will use that CMEK key to
protect the table in BigQuery.
In Dataproc, we support
CMEK at the cluster level.
That CMEK key is
going to be used
to protect the persistent
disks that are in the cluster.
We also allow you to
indicate a storage bucket.
And that storage bucket can be
protected using CMEK as well.
And so implicitly, cloud
storage also supports CMEK.
And we support CMEK as a
default key at the bucket level
or as an object-level CMEK
key when you write an object.
And finally, Persistent
Disk supports CMEK per disk.
So maybe we will move to a demo.
IL-SUNG LEE: This is the cloud
KMS page on the cloud console.
And when you want
to create a HSM key,
it's really, really simple.
Right?
All you have to do
is essentially--
what did I call the key ring?
I called it this.
So I just want to
make sure it coincides
with my little script.
So when you create a key
ring, all you have to do
is specify the key ring
and then make it a region.
Now for HSM keys, you have
to make it in the regions
that HSM support.
And for example, us-west1
is currently supported.
All right.
So that's great.
Then, what you need to
do is, you basically
have to go down and
choose what kind of key.
So you can do things like--
I can create an asymmetric
key, for example, for signing.
And when you
actually do that, you
get a choice of all
the different types
that you can have.
Now, when we say
symmetric key here,
symmetric key here specifically
means AES 256 in GSM mode.
Right?
But for signing, you can get
to choose whatever you like.
And so I'll just pick,
let's say, ECP 256.
All right.
And then I go and say that I
want to create this in the HSM.
And then I'd say create.
Oh.
I have to give the key name.
So like "my demo asym key"
or something like that.
Right?
It doesn't really matter.
And then you do that, and
then it goes and creates
and that's it.
Right?
So if you ever worked
with HSMs before,
you know that creating a
key takes a lot of steps.
Here it's just one flag.
And now you have a
key available to you.
Every time you use that
key, all the operations
will be performed
within the HSM.
The key was created
within HSM, and it's
ready for use with the KMS API.
Now that we have that
we have that key ring
and everything else,
I'm going to show you
how to use the key import
feature that's in alpha.
Now, it's in alpha.
There's no UI
associated with this.
So you have to do it through
either the API or G Cloud.
So I'll do it through
G Cloud, because that's
a little bit easier.
So there's a couple
of things I have
to do to set the environment.
I need to actually set an alias.
It's in alpha, so
you have to download
a private version of G Cloud.
Right?
Hold on a second.
We kill all that.
And then let's see.
I will create that.
And then this, authorize it.
OK.
So now we're all set up.
Right?
And I probably need to
actually go and set up.
So remember I told
you earlier that we're
going to use a little shortcut
to actually do the encryption
and wrapping all within G Cloud?
And so in order to
do that, you need
to actually install the
Python cryptography library.
And I should have
already done that here,
unless the reboot actually
screwed something up.
Hopefully I'll keep
my fingers crossed.
If not, then I'll just
have to redo this.
All right.
Now I created the
key ring already.
And so the first
thing I need to do
is I need to create
an import job.
An import job in our language
is basically just an object
that represents the import key.
And so that job is
basically an import key.
Now this import key
is going to create
a private public key
pair, like I said.
You can download the public key,
and it'll exist for three days.
And so you can use that public
key to import as many keys
as you want for three days.
Afterwards, we have
to create a new one.
OK?
And so if you look
at the syntax here--
please let me know
if it's too small.
It's a big screen.
I think you guys are OK.
So I'm creating us-west1
under the same key ring.
The "next 19 demo key ring
1" I just created up there.
And protection
levels HSM, that's
a flag that tells it that I
want to create this in the HSM
instead of in software.
And then I specify
the import method.
Now, this method.
There's two of them.
There's this one the "RSA
OAEP 3072 sha1 AES 256."
And there's the same
one with a 4K key.
OK?
And so this one, I'm just
going to use it with a 3K key.
So hopefully that goes through.
Fantastic.
And then what I will do
is that I'll list it out
there so that we can see that
the import job is available.
And so there it is right there.
So you can see that the
demo import job is there,
it's active, and the
type of method it is.
So we're all set now.
Now, the next
thing we need to do
is that-- you can actually go
and also see the public key.
So if you were to do
this like with your HSM,
you would need this public key.
And so here's a PEN file.
You can just copy this into
a PEN, you know, import it
and off you go.
Now, what we're going to
do next is that first,
I need to create a crypto key.
And so if you're familiar
with our KMS already,
you have different constructs.
You have that key
ring you created, you
have the keys, which is
actually the container for all
the different key materials,
and then you have versions
under each of the keys.
Right?
And so I'm just going to
create a key, because I'm
going to import a key version.
And put nothing in there.
So that's all I did right here.
I just created a key
with nothing in there.
And then I'm going to
generate a symmetric key.
I'm going to do it the really,
really easy and quick and very,
very official way, which
is to use dev random.
OK.
And I'm just going
to get 256 bits
and put them into
a temporary file.
And then after that, I'm
going to run the import job.
Now, this is where
it's going to fail
if the cryptography package
wasn't installed for Python.
But hopefully
that's still there.
And if you look at
the command right now,
it's the same thing--
location, key ring.
You specify the key that
you're trying to import,
then the target file
where the actual key is,
and then the import
job, and the algorithm,
which is symmetric keys.
OK?
So there we go.
OK.
See?
It didn't work because
this stupid thing reset.
OK so I need to go and actually
do a Pseudo PIP install.
Whoops.
Cryptography.
And so this is probably good
for everyone here to know,
in case you want to do this.
So that you have to
do this, and it works.
So all I'm doing is installing
the proper cryptograph
[INAUDIBLE].
The reason I need to do that
is that this whole RSA AES
key wrap is available in
this cryptography module,
not in Python by itself.
Whoops.
I'm sorry.
I meant to go up one more.
Now I do the import job.
And it should work.
And there you go.
It imported the key.
And so you can see
that it explains
that it's a symmetric key,
what time it was created,
what project, and
that it's enabled.
And this is to show you that
this key actually works.
And just remember that
the key that I created
is called "demo import key 1."
You can see it right there.
I will go and do
a test encryption.
So this one is really simple.
Actually I'm not
going to use the TXT.
I'm going to create a text
file that says "hello world."
All right.
And simple as that.
And then I'm going to run
the standard KMS API--
KMS commands-- to
actually do an encryption.
So you can see
right here all I'm
doing is that I
specify that alpha
came as encrypt, location west,
key ring, everything else.
And then I just give
the cipher file,
and it's going to
export to temp ct.
And so obviously, if
you look at temp ct,
you see that it's just
basically gibberish.
Right?
It's cipher text.
And now if I want to
actually take temp ct,
and I want to actually
decrypt it using that key--
because it's a
symmetric key, right, I
use the same key for
encryption and decryption--
then you'll see that it works.
It says "hello world."
So there you go.
That's all you have to do to
import a key into the HSM.
It's now in there.
OK?
Yeah.
The question is, is this
key visible in the console?
Yes, it is.
So let me go back
here real quickly.
And let me refresh this.
And so there you go.
It says "not available"
because I haven't
defined what a primary key is.
Right?
But, I mean, I
imported that key.
It's version one.
And so you can
still use it as long
as you specify the version.
If you want to use it
without the version,
then you need to set
that as the primary key.
OK?
All right.
Let me turn it over
to Matt real quick
so that he can do his demo now
that we've got this working.
So, you know, the demos are
a lot more entertaining.
The question is, do
I have a timeline
when this is going to be GA?
Not exactly right now.
I mean, I don't expect it to
take too long to reach GA,
but for now, I
mean, we're looking
to get some feedback
from the alpha.
So I encourage you to
actually go and try to sign up
for the alpha, test it out.
And if we get enough
feedback, then we'll
be able to go quickly through
the beta, then GA process.
Thank you.
The question is, would this
be the same process doing GA
or would it be more
integrated with console?
Definitely, you'll
have more UI with this.
The way we do things
typically, not always,
is that in the alpha
releases, we don't normally
have UI support.
But during the beta
time frame, we'll
have full UI, full
support, all that stuff.
Google's definition with
beta is a little bit
different than what most people
really think of as a beta.
Our betas are typically
fully supported.
And we'll have full--
the things are usually
locked down, everything else.
Anything else?
AUDIENCE: Would
you say [INAUDIBLE]
IL-SUNG LEE: We're using
a vendor name Cavium.
Yes.
All right.
Anything else?
Perfect.
How's it going, Matt?
MATTHEW DRISCOLL: Good.
We're all ready to go.
IL-SUNG LEE: All right.
I'll turn over to Matt.
He's got a very
entertaining demo.
MATTHEW DRISCOLL:
So for my demo,
I kind of wanted to check as
many CMEK boxes as possible
in 10 minutes.
So what we're going
to do is we are
going to take a
public BigQuery data
set that is word counts
of Shakespeare's corpus.
We're going to take
that as the input data
into a Dataproc job
that will reaggragate it
across an aggregate.
Not over each work
of Shakespeare,
but across the entire corpus.
So we'll get the word count
across the entire corpus.
When we do that,
we will make sure
that the BigQuery table it goes
back into is protected by CMEK,
the Dataproc job is going
to be protected by CMEK,
and all of the
intermediate files in GCS
will also be protected by CMEK.
And for fun, we'll
make sure that it's
an HSM in London that's
doing the protection,
because British stuff.
So to start, I'll show you--
Oh.
I clicked on the wrong button.
One second.
I'm just going to show
you the input data.
Whoa.
To start, I'm going to show
the input data with a saved
BigQuery query.
So I have the saved
query in BigQuery.
Which-- I am going to open
the query in the editor
and we'll see what
the input data is.
And we can see--
oh wow.
We can see that by each work--
"Hamlet," King Henry--
how many words there are.
So now we're going
to go over to KMS.
And we're going
to create the CMEK
keys that will protect our job.
So this is a little bit
of a different create path
than Il-Sung.
So demo, live.
We're going to put the
key in Europe west2, which
is the London region.
We'll call it the key demo.
And we'll make the
protection level HSM.
So we'll create this.
Now we will go to
our storage bucket.
And so we're going
to create a storage
bucket to store the
intermediate output of the job.
We'll call it demo live.
So now we want to protect the
storage bucket with an HSM key.
This is really,
really easy to do.
I put the storage bucket in
the same region as my HSM key,
I go to my Advanced
Settings, and whoa.
Settings, and I
use a customer managed key.
When I go to this dropdown,
I now see the demo live key
that I just created.
I can choose that.
And what's happening here,
like we talked about earlier,
is I'm getting a prompt to
grant access to the service
account that
represents this bucket.
So now the GCS service account
has access to that specific KMS
key for encrypt and decrypt.
So I'm going to
create this bucket.
I will go back over
now to Dataproc
and create a new cluster.
So, as before, I put
it in Europe west2.
I'm going to use mostly
standard configuration,
but then under
Advanced Options, I'm
going to choose the
cloud storage bucket.
Demo live.
And I am going to add
some metadata that
actually allows me to--
whoa.
Not car.
That's cat.
Helpers.
Metadata.
So I would add these into
the metadata of the cluster
to create the job, which
I'll skip because it's
a little copy-paste-y.
And then I'm going to choose
a customer managed encryption
key.
So when I choose the customer
managed encryption key,
just like before-- demo live--
we'll be asked to grant
access to the service account.
It takes a little bit of time
to spin up a Dataproc job.
So I'm not going to do
that live right now.
Instead, I'm going
to show you how
this works for the job
I've already created.
So now what's happened is
I've created a HSM key,
I've created a Cloud Storage
bucket to store the key,
and I've configured that
Dataproc job to actually use
our HSM key.
And so you'll see when I
actually submit a job-- oh.
And the last piece-- sorry.
And I'll show you
this after I run it.
But the last piece is--
in this Python script that's
going to run and actually do
the aggregation,
there is a line that
indicates when it creates the
destination table in BigQuery
to use a KMS key to also
protect the destination
table in BigQuery.
So if I run this and the
demo gods are on my side,
we should get an output.
All right.
So our job is running.
We're coming down to
the wire on time here.
So hopefully it runs fast.
So you see that
output of the job.
We're actually getting word
counts out, which is great.
And now we're
writing to BigQuery.
You can see that job's running.
And the job's complete.
So let's go back to BigQuery.
And I'm going to look
at my word count output.
And I'm going to
query this table.
And I'm just going to select
star from the output table.
And just for fun,
I'm going to say
where a word equals Matthew.
See how many times I
appear in Shakespeare.
And did no rows--
three times.
So now what we just did is
we actually read data out
of BigQuery, we pulled
it through a Dataproc job
that processed the data.
We wrote that output
back to BigQuery.
And all of the intermediate
data and the output
was protected by CMEK.
So now, to prove
this to you, I'm
going to go over to the
cryptographic keys again.
And then this key was using--
not demo live.
Demo Europe west2.
And I'm going to
select this key.
And I'm going to revoke
everybody's permission
to use this key.
Sorry.
Show info panel.
So like we said, there
were service accounts
that can use this key.
It has two members.
I'm going to remove
these permissions.
And I'm also going to
remove the permission
for a key that is protecting
the BigQuery data set.
And in the meantime, I'll
show you that key was "cat
word_count.py."
And we're going to
just grep for key.
So in that file, we
had a KMS key set.
That's the key that was
on the BigQuery table.
And so now we will
try to rerun this job.
And it should hopefully fail.
And in the meantime, we're going
to go back over to BigQuery.
Run this query again.
Oh.
Give it a second for the
permissions to update.
All right.
Well, we're down to
the last 30 seconds.
Great.
So you see permission
denied on KMS key.
So now, because we protected
everything with KMS,
we can use KMS as a way to
control access to the data.
So we have 47 seconds left.
So that's about it for the demo.
Any last-minute questions?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MATTHEW DRISCOLL: It is.
MATTHEW DRISCOLL: Yep.
So we could have used the key
that Il-Sung created, and I
would have been able to
do all of the same things.
So it's pretty powerful.
Right?
Like, in about five minutes,
we just sort of created
a bunch of keys in an HSM.
You could import your own
material if you wanted to.
I can use those keys to protect
both the intermediate steps
and the outputs of a
data processing job
that spans three or
four Google products.
Right?
So this is compliance
across a pretty relatively
complex pipeline in a few
minutes and a couple of clicks.
So yeah.
With that, can we flip
back to the presentation
for one minute?
All right.
So the takeaway.
So Google Cloud makes
managing encryption
easy for compliance-sensitive
workloads.
A few things we really hope
you take away today are--
Cloud HSM allows simple
and scalable access
to hardware-protected
keys, including inputting
your own key material.
Cloud KMS enables
easy management
of all of your encryption
keys, regardless of
whether or not
they're in an HSM.
And then CMEK enables you to
control encryption across all--
not all-- some GCP
services very simply
to achieve your
compliance goals.
Thanks very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]